10 Lockean lon t equal about 14 euros
but first you'll have to stand in line
to get the new euro coins at this Bank
in riga more than 20 years after
independence the country is now going
through its third currency change first
there was the Latvian ruble then the
lots and now the euro many Latvians are
not looking forward to the common
currency while the euro debt crisis
continues at the petco I think the
majority are against the introduction of
the euro because we don't know what to
expect above all older people will
struggle to get used to the new currency
mine official finish allow do during a
referendum lat pans voted in favor of
joining the EU ten years ago the
government says that adopting the euro
was part of the deal and pushed through
the currency change in Parliament
opinion pollster arnaz kotkin says many
Latvians are unhappy about losing a
symbol of their independence it turned
out that only twenty percent expressed
support versus more than majority 53
express disagreement with our joining
from switching from left of the euro
some twenty percent told us that they
have natural attitude it means that
actually they are neither for neither
against not being exporters such as you
PB stand to benefit most from the
adoption of the euro the medium-sized
enterprise providing engineering
services and construction materials
boasts more than 100 million euros and
annual sales the combination of
relatively low wages and a youthful
workforce has helped upp achieved
success in Western Europe its future
depends heavily on exports because the
domestic market is far too small this
combined heat and power unit is being
produced for export to Germany owner
will dispel ins will be able to save a
lot of money because his company will no
longer have to pay currency exchange
fees for foreign orders he says he's
glad that latvia is wait for the euro is
now over
yes in Shan mean we're already in the
eurozone because the lots was already
pegged to the euro four or five years
ago so we are integrated that makes us
more competitive and we already have
some experience Latvia is the 18th
country to join the eurozone but most
Latvians are not yet convinced that the
common currency will be advantageous